significa que cuanto más cerca del blanco uno esté en ese espectro,
mejor estará.
Y que cuanto más cerca del negro uno esté en ese espectro,
peor estará.
Cuando pensamos la forma de abordar problemas en este país,
a menudo empezamos desde un lugar de la justicia por derrame.
Así, con los blancos como control, decimos
bien, si mejoramos las cosas para los blancos
todos saldrán beneficiados.
Pero en realidad no funciona así.
Tenemos que atacar los problemas de raíz,
y al lidiar con lo que sucede en las comunidades negras,
eso crea una efervescencia, ¿sí?
Un burbujeo hacia arriba más que un derrame hacia abajo.
Daré un ejemplo.
Cuando hablamos de la brecha salarial,
a menudo decimos que las mujeres ganan 78 centavos por cada dólar de los hombres.
Todos han oído eso antes.
Pero esas son estadísticas para mujeres blancas y hombres blancos.
La realidad indica que las mujeres negras ganan 64 centavos
por cada 78 centavos de las mujeres blancas.
Las latinas, ganan 58 centavos.
Y si hablamos de mujeres aborígenes,
si hablamos de mujeres trans,
el número sería incluso más bajo.
De nuevo,
si uno trabaja con los más impactados,
todos tendrán la oportunidad de beneficiarse de eso,
en vez de trabajar con los menos impactados,
y esperar que derrame hacia abajo.
MB: Me encanta la efervescencia,
el burbujeo hacia arriba.
AG: Efervescencia, como el champán.
(Risas)
MB: ¿A quién no le gusta una copa de champán, ¿no?
Champán y libertad, ¿no?
(Risas)
¿Qué más podríamos desear, no?
Todos lo hemos hecho durante un minuto,
y los últimos años han sido...
bueno, no puedo ni imaginarlo,
pero seguro han sido transformadores.
Y sé que todos han aprendido mucho sobre liderazgo.
¿Qué deseas compartir con estas personas
sobre lo que has aprendido del liderazgo?
Patrisse, empecemos contigo.
PC: Sí, tenemos que invertir en el liderazgo negro.
Ese es mi mejor aprendizaje en los últimos años.
(Aplausos)
Hemos visto miles de negros que se presentan en nuestras vidas
con muy poca infraestructura y muy poco apoyo.
El trabajo como líderes del movimiento no se trata de la propia visibilidad
sino de dar visibilidad al conjunto.
No de bregar por nosotros,
sino de bregar por todos.
Y pienso, también,
que el liderazgo se parece a este público
que se ocupa de las vidas negras.
No se trata solo de venir a ver personas en el escenario, ¿no?
Se trata de cómo volverse líder,
ya sea en el lugar de trabajo, o en el hogar,
y de creer que el movimiento por las vidas negras no es solo para nosotros,
sino para todos.
(Aplausos)
MB: ¿Qué hay de ti, Opal?
OT: He estado aprendiendo mucho sobre la interdependencia.
He estado aprendiendo a confiar en el equipo.
He encontrado este nuevo mantra
después de regresar de un sabático de tres meses,
que es raro que tomen las mujeres negras en puestos de liderazgo,
pero sentí que era realmente importante para mi liderazgo y para mi equipo
practicar también retroceder
así como también a veces ingresar.
Y en este proceso aprendí que debemos reconocer
que distintas personas aportan diferentes puntos fuertes,
y que, para que todo el equipo florezca,
tenemos que permitirles compartir y permitirles brillar.
Por eso durante mi sabático
con la organización con la que trabajo,
vi a nuestro equipo levantarse en mi ausencia.
Pudieron lanzar nuevos programas,
recaudar fondos.
Y, cuando volví,
tuve que darles mucha gratitud y reconocimiento
porque me mostraron que contaban con mi apoyo
pero que, verdaderamente, tenían sus propias espaldas.
Saben, en mi sabático
recordé realmente
la filosofía sudafricana de ubuntu.
"Soy porque tú eres;
tú eres porque yo soy".
Y me di cuenta de que mi propio liderazgo,
y las contribuciones que puedo hacer,
se deben en gran parte a las contribuciones que ellos hacen, ¿no?
Y tengo que reconocer que, y tengo que ver que,
por eso mi nuevo mantra es: "Mantén la calma y confía en el equipo".
Y también:
"Mantén la calma y agradece al equipo".
MB: Sabes, una de las cosas que siento que he escuchado
en el contexto del movimiento Black Lives Matter más que en otro lugar
es un movimiento de co-liderazgo,
y ese es un concepto muy hermoso,
y creo que algo
que las mujeres a menudo aportan a la conversación sobre liderazgo
es realmente la pieza colectiva.
¿Qué hay de ti, Alicia?
AG: Sí...
¿Cuántos de Uds. han oído decir que el liderazgo es solitario?
Creo que hay un elemento donde el liderazgo es solitario,
pero también creo que no tiene por qué ser así.
Y para llegar a ese punto,
creo que hay algunas cosas que debemos hacer.
Una es que tenemos que dejar de tratar a los líderes como superhéroes.
Somos gente común que trata de hacer cosas poco comunes,
por eso necesitamos apoyo.
Otra cosa que aprendí del liderazgo
es que hay una diferencia entre ser líder y ser celebridad, ¿no?
En cierto modo nos hemos convertido en celebridades
en vez de personas que tratan de resolver un problema.
Y tratamos a las celebridades de manera un poco lábil, ¿no?
Un día nos gustan,
al otro día no nos gusta lo que llevan puesto,
y de repente tenemos problemas, ¿no?
Por eso debemos dejar de endiosar a los líderes
para que más personas asuman el liderazgo.
Mucha gente está aterrorizada de saltar al liderazgo
por el escrutinio excesivo que reciben
y por lo brutales que somos con los líderes.
Y luego lo último que he aprendido sobre el liderazgo
es que es fácil ser líder cuando le gustas a todo el mundo.
Pero es difícil ser líder si debes tomar decisiones difíciles
y si tienes que hacer lo correcto,
aun cuando no le gustes a la gente justamente por eso.
Y así, de esa manera,
pienso en otra manera para apoyar a los líderes
es sumarse a nuestra lucha,
sumarse a nuestra lucha políticamente,
no de forma personal.
Podemos tener desacuerdos sin ser desagradables,
pero es importante para nosotros que nos potenciemos mutuamente,
para que todos podamos levantarnos.
MB: Eso es hermoso, gracias.
(Aplausos)
Uds. están haciendo un trabajo
que las obliga a enfrentar realidades brutales, dolorosas,
a diario.
¿Qué les da esperanza
y las inspira en ese contexto?
PC: Tengo esperanza por los futuros negros.
Y lo digo porque vivimos en una sociedad
obsesionada por la muerte negra.
Tenemos imágenes de nuestra muerte en la pantalla de TV,
en las líneas de tiempo de Twitter,
o en las de Facebook,
pero ¿qué tal si imaginamos la vida negra?
Imaginamos a los negros vivos y prósperos.
Y eso...
eso me inspira.
OT: Lo que me inspira estos días son los inmigrantes.
Inmigrantes en todo el mundo que están haciendo lo mejor que pueden
para ganarse la vida, sobrevivir y también para prosperar.
Ahora mismo hay más de 244 millones de personas
que no viven en su país de origen.
Se trata de un aumento del 40 % desde el año 2000.
Eso me dice que
las disparidades en todo el mundo solo están empeorando.
Sin embargo, hay personas que encuentran la fuerza y los medios para viajar,
para moverse,
para conseguir una vida mejor para ellos mismos
y para sus familias y seres queridos.
Y algunas de estas personas son inmigrantes
y también indocumentados.
No están autorizados.
Y me inspiran aún más
porque aunque nuestra sociedad le está diciendo Uds. no son queridos,
no los necesitamos aquí,
y son muy vulnerables y sujeto a abuso, a robo de sueldo,
a explotación y a ataques xenófobos,
muchos de ellos también están empezando a organizarse en sus comunidades.
Y estoy viendo que también hay una red emergente
de la población negra, indocumentada, que se resiste al marco,
y resiste la criminalización de su existencia.
Y eso para mí es increíblemente poderoso
y me inspira cada día.
MB: Gracias.
¿Alicia?
AG: Sabemos que los jóvenes son el presente y el futuro,
pero me inspiran las personas mayores
que se están transformando al servicio de este movimiento.
Sabemos que conforme uno envejece,
se atrinchera un poco más en sus formas.
Me ocurre a mí, sé que eso es correcto.
Pero me inspira ver a la gente que tiene una forma de hacer cosas,
que tiene una forma de pensar el mundo,
y son valientes como para estar abiertos a escuchar las experiencias
de tantos de nosotros que queremos vivir en un mundo justo
y queremos vivir en un mundo equitativo.
Y también me inspiran las acciones de las personas mayores que veo
al servicio de este movimiento.
Me inspira ver gente mayor asumir su propio poder y liderazgo
y decir: "No estoy pasando una antorcha,
estoy ayudando a encender el fuego".
(Aplausos)
MB: Me encanta eso,
sí.
En términos de acción,
creo que es increíble sentarse aquí y poder escucharlas a Uds.,
y tener nuestras mentes abiertas y flexibles,
pero eso no va a liberar a las personas negras.
Así que si tuvieran algo que quisieran que este público
y quienes están mirando en el mundo hicieran,
¿qué sería?
AG: Bien, dos rápidas.
Una, llamar a la Casa Blanca.
Están eliminando los protectores de agua por la fuerza
del campamento que han montado para defender lo que nos mantiene vivos.
Y eso está relacionado intrincadamente con las vidas negras.
Definitivamente, llamen a la Casa Blanca y exijan que dejen de hacer eso.
Hay tanques
y agentes de policía deteniendo a cada persona allí mientras hablamos.
(Aplausos)
La segunda cosa que pueden hacer
es unirse a algo.
Sean parte de algo.
Hay grupos, colectivos...
no tiene que ser una ONG, ¿saben a lo que me refiero?
Pero hay grupos que están trabajando en nuestras comunidades ahora
para que las vidas negras importen así todas las vidas importan.
Participen;
no se sienten en el sofá y digan qué piensan que se debe hacer.
Háganlo con nosotros.
MB: ¿Quieres agregar algo?
¿Está bien? Todo bien. Así que...
Y pienso que al sumarse a algo,
si sienten que no tienen a qué sumarse, creen algo.
AG: Créenlo.
MB: Estas conversaciones que entablamos,
conversen de esto con otras personas.
Y en vez de dejar que sea una charla que tuvieron,
decidan crear algo.
OT: Correcto.
MB: Digo, es lo que hicieron Uds.
Crearon algo y vieron qué pasaba.
Muchas gracias a todas por estar aquí con nosotros hoy.
OT: Gracias.
(Aplausos)